people who don't have purpose
become Wayward you know what is it the
Idle Hands the Devil's Playground so you
have a bunch of people who have nothing
to do no Specialties no expertise
they're just listless wandering NPCs or
whatever irrelevant and so in this
hollow hole in their heart they fill it
with fake purpose and so they join the
machine and that's why they're so
adamant about never giving it up no
matter what why is it that we had Larry
Elder here and he says you know I tried
showing the quote the transcription from
Trump where Trump did not say you know
very fine people and stuff he said the
white supremacist should be condemned
totally and they refuse to read it it's
because they have nothing in their
hearts and and and so you know for me
I play music I play Magic the Gathering
I skateboard I rollerblade uh we're
writing songs we we talk politics I am
very full of purpose
but what about someone who has nothing
what about someone who's not really that
good at playing guitar what if someone's
not really good at playing games what if
someone has no hobbies and they have no
friends
the only thing they have is to latch
onto this ideology that's the one thing
they have and then you come along the
nerve of you trying to give them the
truth which would shatter the only thing
they have in their hearts they won't
allow that they go nuts and that's why
they they get violent on behalf of it
it's the only thing they have but their
only passion you're spot on I think
that's exactly it but I think it's the
same reason people sometimes go really
far right it's the same reason people
get into Scientology or Mormonism or
whatever it is often they don't quite
have something in their lives I always
remember you know when I I was a bit uh
I don't think I was woke but maybe liver
when I was like 18 19 years old you go
to university right you know when you go
and everybody's got in their dorms like
posters of the of like this is who I am
I'm someone who likes The Godfather and
it's like well Everyone likes The
Godfather you know but that's my
individuality and and hopefully as you
get older you start to as you say take
up more interests you don't identify it
you know everyone's gotten their pronoun
you know pronouns or whatever it might
be in their Twitter profile and you know
why do we need to know or that well I
want to know if you play guitar as you
say I want to know what you do in your
life what's interesting and those are
the people I think sometimes who are LED
into cultish groups they don't have
anything like me no Ma so uh I like to
skate was uh was a rollerblading alert
today and every day when I do I'm trying
to one-up myself
so I'm trying to go higher on the vert
ramp or I'm trying to do something I've
never done before and that that's
fulfilling and it's accomplishment I'm
challenging myself every day but for if
you're someone who doesn't have that
then the only thing you have to give you
that dopamine release is going to be
fitting in and having someone else
praise you or feeling like you know
you're latched onto something or eating
yeah eating or eating anything maybe
that's why a lot of them are morbidly
obese no joke if you feel depression you
want serotonin you eat that's a big
thing that definitely raises your mood
well you know and the food's being
engineered to become addictive but
that's another uh process in itself I
remember a couple years ago looking at
psychological studies specifically when
it came to radical jihadists and a lot
of psychologists found that it was
poverty and polyamory that led to of
course people becoming radicalists
because there there wasn't enough women
for the guys to go around one guy would
marry 10 to 12 to 15 to 20 wives and
there wasn't enough wives to go around
because of the poverty because of the
lack of Education a lot of people just
you know went to extremist groups so
when you look at those conditions when
you look at what's happening in in
today's day and age in the dating world
when you look at what's happening
financially with the banks and the big
multinational corporations pretty much
stealing everyone's money we're pretty
much creating the same situation for
radicalization so uh yes the things are
not going to be good with so many people
radicalized with so many people going to
the fringes and going to these extremist
groups that they're going to be taking
advantage of with and now we have the
Cults becoming prominent in government
in major corporations and institutions
uh
have you have you studied or read up on
other tradition more traditional Cults
stuff like Scientology or Nexium or
those kinds of things sure I don't know
about those specifically those are more
modern but I mean there have been you
know uh it was it Jim Jones is that his
name yeah yeah yeah Jonestown Johnstown
that was mad I I use those because I
think we have well actually uh
Scientology might be a good example as
well but I think Jonestown is it's very
definitive it had an end there's a lot
of that we know about it what what are
are there similarities or can you can
you look at something like that and then
try and predict where we go with the
modern woke cult well Jonestown I think
is is really rare just in terms of how I
mean I use the word cultish to think you
know something is cultist maybe it's one
out of ten cultists and Jonestown was 10
out of 10. Scientology is like a nine
out of 10 or 10 out of 10 or something
uh Heaven's Gate was the other one do
you remember that one oh yeah was that
where they thought they were going to go
on the the comment or whatever yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I mean did they drink the
Kool-Aid too yeah so that's actually a
misnomer the Kool-Aid thing I think it
wasn't Kool-Aid it was something else
but it got remembered it's called yeah I
love how it you know always like this
this story is it's relatively modern I
was in the 90s yeah I think so and now
drink the Kool-Aid has become like a
slang term for buying into something and
it's wrong oh it's flavored yeah it was
flavored yeah oh not flavored it was uh
cyanide poison force and if you there's
video audio of them eating it and people
didn't want to they were refusing they
were screaming they were taking babies
away from mothers to poison the baby and
the mothers were screaming I think it's
horrific it's on YouTube are you talking
about Jim Jones now Jonestown I don't
know about um Heaven's gay so Jonestown
they yeah people believe that they all
killed themselves and they're like how
did that happen and that's not really
what happened they tried to escape as
you say and there were security guards
just shooting them and killing them all
dead dude it's like a 40 minute video
because they're cultists the guy in
charge Jim Jones was being caught I
think uh the FBI I think it was it would
have been the CIA what were in Guyana
sort of checking up on him and he knew
his days were numbered right so it was
like okay this is the next step we all
have to we all have to kill ourselves
now so I think it's rare that people get
absolutely swept up to a point that
they're willing to actually kill
themselves like that I think there's and
I think that's the same with the a lot
of you know we talk about the woke
ideology stuff I think deep deep down
and the woke stuff goes back to the new
Puritans I talk about the Puritans
Andrew Doyle is great on that I I
interviewed him recently and he's
fantastic he's got this book with the
new Puritans
um just about how similar the witch
hunting stuff is to a lot of the woke
ideology and they knew it wasn't real
the Witch Hunter people but they knew
that if they said anything just like now
yeah if they said anything they'd be
next you get shadowed down right yeah so
so that's probably the closest thing I
think in terms of like historic Cults
and how that relates to today so maybe
in 50 to 100 years they'll talk about
the cancel culture trials and how absurd
and crazy everybody was and uh I think
so we'll come out on the right side of
this one is so it's that they think that
if they if they cause enough pain to the
enemy that they're actually causing good
to the ones they I mean I don't
understand like what was the impetus of
the witch hunts why were they doing it
I've heard that they were got that they
were inadvertently dosing themselves
with ergot
fungus on wheat that causes
hallucinations and so they were tripping
balls they didn't know it so they
thought he's a witch he's a witch I'm a
wit they didn't know and it's also
slightly it also has to do with the fact
that people have like the hag's dream
have you ever heard of that the
hagstream when you fall asleep and you
feel like someone's in the room right
right it's just an evolutionary trade
that allows you to think oh if there's
something in the room you're awake but
you're not moving your body keeps you
from moving sleep paralysis my
girlfriend has to wake me up I'm like
I'm like in my head I'm screaming I
think I'm screaming I'm gonna go ah
right now but what's actually happening
is I'm going
which is freaky for my girlfriend at
four in the morning like she's got to be
like okay
wake me up and all that it's just like
it's it's it's freaky yeah but but
that's it but the thing with the witch
thing and which also relates to modern
times because you guys were talking
before about when it's powerful people
it doesn't you know the same rules don't
apply the the girls that were accusing
everyone they did towards the end when
it was falling apart they did accuse
people who were quite prominent right
and everybody just sort of went what
shut up yeah and then they had to shut
up after the witch hunts yes yeah yeah
wow yeah they tried to reach too high
yeah and then powerful people said no
kind of like when they went after Rogan
with the Ivermectin thing yes well not
just that they wanted to run for a lot
of things and they just doesn't work
nothing sticks yeah sometimes it's you
it's overt nonsense you you realize yeah
well that's what happens eventually the
the veil gets shattered I guess and
people are just like okay oh wait a
minute you know what's really going on
here yeah but I think it's it's like
most things it's just confidence do the
people have enough confidence of other
people to to to engage in insane
Behavior people were like even really
intelligent people I mean all of us will
probably get misled and let down certain
rabbit holes and we don't even realize
it my favorite example is Arthur Conan
Doyle who wrote Sherlock Holmes and he's
supposed to be the master of deduction
Sherlock Holmes so Arthur Conan doors
super clever person and there's a great
book called the intelligence trap about
exactly this the cleverer the person is
the better able they are to convince
themselves of Mads can
because they're smart so it's
confirmation bias so Arthur Conan Doyle
believed in fairies and that was at a
time when people did not believe in
fairies no no it wasn't like oh but it
was back in the olden times but he just
was obsessed and he was mates with
Houdini the magician and Houdini was
like a absolute skeptic and they fell
out over that what yeah big argument
over that and also because
um Arthur Conan Doyle kept trying to get
um Houdini to do this like Clairvoyant
stuff and like speak to his dead mother
and mad stuff like that and he's like
it's that real yeah and avocado was like
those fairies are real but the fairies
were pranked by some young girls they
just put up some pictures of fairies and
put like a drawing pin in the in the
stomach and just put it like little
paper fairies and he believed that and
he thought that the drawing pin the
little pin in the stomach that was
evidence that they had belly buttons and
so they so they had children it was like
fairies can reproduce that was what he
was thinking this is a super smart guy
so I think what's happening is as you
said there's like all these people who
are perhaps really intelligent like we
like to think of oh you joined science
you must be an idiot a lot of them is
really into I've met some really
intelligent ex-scientologists but maybe
they're lacking some sort of purpose and
then someone comes along and says no no
you've got purpose you're going to sign
a one billion year contract which is
what they have to do and you're gonna
with each bit of money you put in you're
going to learn more secret stuff about
um aliens and Lords you know who that's
Scientology that's Scientology they have
it's a billion year contract yeah yeah
what yeah because you because you're
Immortal or something do you know the
Scientology backstory only a little bit
about the theaters yeah yeah we've been
dropping them in the volcano and stuff
that's fantastic so they they now say
this isn't what they think but it is it
is this is the problem with the Internet
it's ruined Cults because Cults are
supposed to be there's supposed to be a
level that you can't reach because it's
like the secret level right until you
put enough money in but now we have the
internet so it's just there so now
Scientology has to go out and say no no
no that's not true until you get to that
stage negotia was true actually
um so it is there Lord Zeno and and
Lords they'll live somewhere else and he
killed everyone in this alien planet and
all the spirits went away into Earth
into the volcanoes of Earth and it went
out into everybody's yeah bodies now and
now you have like a bunch of ghosts
inside you or something is that it yeah
I was I was I was in Hollywood now
skating I knew they got the Scientology
thing on Hollywood Boulevard yeah and I
think it's on Hollywood was that the
street I live right next to it it's
between Sunset and Franklin or Holland
Franklin so I'm skating and then I see a
guy with the book and he's outside and
he's waving as I'm coming up so I stop
and then he's like hey how's it going he
talks to me and um he asked me if I knew
anything about Dianetics because that I
think that's what it says like it's like
Scientology and then I was like No And
he was like do you know anything about
scientology and I was like just what
I've seen from the TV I was like don't
you guys believe like aliens and like
volcanoes and he goes that's what the uh
the cartoon says do you get all your
facts from cartoons South Park and I was
like no and he goes oh so how about we
actually tell you what we do and I was
like sure they came in and sat down and
then they gave me the e-meter and then
yeah yeah for real and then I put my
hands on it or whatever and like I'm
like nothing's happening I have no idea
you're talking about and then the guy
asked me if I would be interested in in
better understanding and buying the book
so I actually bought dynetics now I'm
sweet completely skeptical I think it's
like 20 bucks yeah but I was like how
can I be critical of something I've
never actually read if I don't know what
they're talking about it's simple for me
to watch South Park and then like the
the TV said you're dumb but that would
be stupid and so I think I actually got
maybe like 50 pages in and then laughed
and then put it down I was like I can't
read this because I think I think for me
it seemed really obvious how the
manipulation worked it it it's like a
it's like my view of it is a it's a
false logic like it'll say something hey
did you ever experience this feeling
yeah that's because of this thing and
then you go oh I could see how that
works if they can make you using
sophistry go from point A to point B to
C to D to e they're walking you towards
they're creating the reality they're
they're building a logical structure for
you to and I read that and I was just
like you know people fall for this stuff
they read it and believe it speaking on
the Integrity of Scientology I lived in
Hollywood and did a uh a video a movie
for the Scientology group they had me
and my girlfriend come in they want to
do something on the right to marriage so
they're like okay for this you guys are
married tell everyone how happy you are
so we're like okay so we faked lied that
we were they got a non-married couple to
pretend like they were married because
they like the way they looked like what
you're gonna say you had to lie that you
were happy but no you know we had a lie
that we were married so this is like a
church technically telling telling
having non-mare married people pretend
that they're married like it's it's a
lie I was lying uh for the
scientologists and they paid me to lie
for them yeah sounds like them I wanna I
wanna jump to another segment but we're
gonna we're gonna grab the super that
just came in sleep is the cousin of
death says Tim making fun of Scientology
but thinks God's real oh boy you see
this is this is the challenging thing I
guess about trying to talk to people
about physics spirituality reality
understanding philosophy Etc et cetera
um I I I could be wrong but Einstein
believed in God he was not an atheist
that's where the phrase Einstein God
comes from maybe it's wrong but the idea
of Einstein God is it's that phrase is
used to explain to people who don't
understand uh
they don't understand I guess how do you
describe it Concepts Beyond knowledge
right the infinity what does infinity
truly mean how do you perceive
Dimensions we you know beyond three so
there are certain ideas that we
understand can exist but it's hard for
us to conceptualize we can describe
so with the issue of Einstein God you
talk to your average person you say like
describe God and they'll say you know a
guy with a beard he's in the clouds and
he's got white hair or whatever and
that's like a weird cartoon depiction of
some religious deity but for this is why
I say I don't believe in any organized
religion
the simplest way to put it is
God in my view is just there is a system
by which we exist in we understand the
system of a computer program we
understand that we as humans are mapping
out reality
the simplest way to put it is God is the
universe there is a greater power that
exists Beyond us it is the structure and
code of the universe it exists that's
the most rudimentary way to explain to
someone who thinks God is a person in
the clouds now a lot of religious people
genuinely do believe that God is a
person who is above us or around us or
whatever and that's on them but if
you're if your assumption immediately is
when I say I believe in God you think
I'm talking about a guy in the sky then
you are not then you you genuinely do
not know enough about the subject and I
don't mean that disrespectfully I mean
my my view of this comes from Reading
religious texts growing up briefly
Catholic reading about quantum physics
reading a philosophy and then going
we don't know half we don't we don't we
don't know anything we know so little
and when you when you know from that
perspective
I would I would need probably a couple
hours we've done this in the members
only shows breaking down the The Long
Trail of thought to understand the
concept that I'm that I'm trying to get
to there's no way I could do it in 10
minutes you know without making a whole
show dedicated to it but uh simply put
my view of God is not a guy in the
clouds it is it is well well well beyond
that I want you to imagine Infinity you
know what Infinity means right A lot of
people think Infinity is a number it's
not Infinity means everything Beyond and
endlessly and and I want you to imagine
things that don't exist I want you to
imagine a color you've never seen before
I want you to imagine the fourth
dimension how do you do it you can't you
can understand for a three-dimensional
projection of the fourth dimension and
we can mathematically show how a fourth
dimension will work even though we can't
conceptualize it outside of just drawing
a mathematical picture thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast dot com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there